bonsoir dauphin alors qu'à tallinn je me
lève et je te bouscule
tu ne te réveille pas comme d'habitude
vous parlez français encore non pas du
tout bon je comprends que
je suis désolé je ne t'apprends beaucoup
mais je crois je crois qu'on va rester
avec la traductrice j'appelais comment
ou alors on annule
vous appelez comment t'est simin dons
soit
comment ça va ça va bien merci 9
excusez nous pour la dernière fois on
est partis comme des voleurs
bien alors que kalin bonsoir katalin
jones man au jour où catalina tabelles
aujourd'hui vous vivez dans un ranch
près de santa barbara en californie avec
votre mari joe haldeman et et vos deux
enfants brandon 11 ans et william dix
ans alors est-ce que les gens là bas
autour de vous en californie savent
qu'il y à 26 ans le 11 mars
1978 vous aviez 23 ans à paris boulevard
exelmans le chanteur claude françois est
mort sous vos yeux
[Musique]
bien sûr mes proches ma famille alors
prêté dans katalin la dernière fiancée
de cloclo une aventure amoureuse qui a
duré 18 mois et vous aviez jusqu'ici
toujours refusé de faire des livres de
faire des émissions de télévision
pourquoi parler aujourd'hui
qu'un ferry de grands
éditeurs et m'a demandé s'il voulait
écrire tout d'abord je vis
au cours des 25 dernières années j'ai
gardé vraiment tout donné je me suis dit
allez je vais demander à ma famille donc
j'ai posé la question à mon mari et
il voulait savoir finalement ce qu'avait
fait leur maman avant d'épouser leur
tête ils
veulent savoir si j'avais une vie avant
leur père alors non vous savez il ya
beaucoup de questions sur la mort
effectivement de claude françois
beaucoup d'hypothèses vous le savez on
en a parlé de suicide on a parlé d'
overdose de drogue on a dit qu'ils
avaient été électrocutées avec un
vibromasseur alors que le vibromasseur
je le dis à tout le monde ça marche ça
marche avec des piles ça marche pas sur
220 x janin qui marche au fioul
on a dit des trucs terre il a dit qu'il
était mort en compagnie d'un autre homme
enfin et c'est donc effectivement pour
que la vérité soit dite une fois pour
toutes vous avez fait un livre qui
s'appelle c'est comme ça que l'on s'est
aimé chez michel lafon en souvient la
chanson que vous aviez enregistré en duo
avec claude françois
c'est
des draps froissés
jamais
payer
[Musique]
on sait
on sait combien
beau
[Musique]
mahdi un peu trop
c'est ça
ces mêmes
t
sérieusement quand vous êtes chez vous
en californie à santa barbara vous
écouter cette chanson dance dance et
goûter des 10 claude françois ou non
non j'ai une autre ville
et parfois mes enfants me demandent
à me disait tu as chanté une chanson
géniale as écouté ma chanson bien sûr
mais je dirais que c'est vraiment une
autre vie fois légèrement mais qui
téléphonent à la maison des crois qu'ils
entendent et
alors donc j'avais fait ce duo en 1977
avec claude françois et c'est un succès
d'ailleurs et au moment du mixage final
claude françois a gardé la prise de son
du studio sur laquelle vous rigoliez
vous marier et alors ce qui était
terrible pour vous c'est après quand
vous allez faire la promotion de la
chanson la télévision il fallait que
vous riez sur comment on s est essayé
pour vous c'était un cauchemar
mais chaque fois que je devais rire
claude lenay derrière moi mais toucher
les épaules en tout cas je rien bon
alors voilà vous avez une vie
extraordinaire veut dire vous êtes né en
1954 à los angeles père ingénieur dans
l'électronique mère femme au foyer
famille unie et puis complètement par
hasard à l'âge de 15 ans ou fait des
photos pour des pour des maillots de
bain parce que vous aviez un ami d'une
copine qui avait un magazine de deux
maillots de bain ensuite fait des pubs
vous rencontrer et linford chef d'une
grande grande agence de mannequins états
unis qui vous demande de travailler avec
elle vous refusez vous refusez de la new
york et vous aller à milan tout seul dit
je vais à milan vous avez 20 ans et un
an et demi plus tard vous rencontré
martin de guerre ce modèle qui est qu
est l agence de mannequins de claude
françois qui vous propose de venir
travailler à paris dans l' agence donc
de claude françois à ce moment là vous
saviez qui est écoute françois
marie jo dassin
non non plus derrière la main non elle
débarque et de s'intéresser aux riches
valentin non
j'écoutais les stores vous allez porter
l'habit alors
vous arrivez donc vous arrivez à paris
nous trouver dans l' agence garde ce
modèle les trois premiers mois il se
passe rien claude est assez indifférent
alors on pense être un moment que c'est
un jeu c'est à dire que quand il est
vraiment tiré par rapport à une fille on
vous dit en fait il fait semblant de ne
pas s'intéresser à elle donc vous dites
c'était un jeu et puis malgré tout ça
avance un petit peu un jour et vous
invite en week-end au moulin le fameux
moulin de dannemois donc et vous refusez
je voulais visiter paris alors plutôt
que terran c'est un mois je voulais
aller faire des courses à paris le
premier dans paris sur les
champs-elysées où la rue
des moulins quand même
j'aime vivre ici plutôt qu'à côté génial
soit en faire une copie
charge par la police et elle a dit que
j'étais millions l année
donc voilà au début vous vous refusez
daleo au moulin et puis bon petit à
petit il insiste un petit peu lourdement
et vous acceptez mais le premier
week-end vous allez au moulin avec
autres en soit il se passer se passe
rien n'y a pas de rien de sexuel jeudi
un premier week-end
bon je passe les étapes enfin morin
jours après après vous y allez tous les
week-ends quoi mais c'est quoi les
étapes en fait
les états
c'est une invitation à dîner autour de
laquelle claude raconte à katalin un
petit peu sa vie ce qu'ils pensent tout
ça par le dîner qu'on fait
habituellement dans ces cas là quoi en
se dévoilant un petit peu et puis après
bon ben c'est tous les week-ends au
moulin ce que ce film dense a loupé les
étapes à quoi alors voilà donc vous
devenez la fiancée officielle de claude
françois et puis vous êtes présenté un
petit peu au tout paris lors d'une
soirée de lancement pour son eau de
toilette qui s'appelait au noir dans la
boîte laventure de de dany et là vous
arrivez en robe du soir pour cette
soirée évidemment c'est une soirée très
importante pour vous et vous rendez
compte que tout le monde et en jean en
fait et vous vous sentez un petit peu
ridicule un peu comme ce sont
aujourd'hui
j'avais également les droits des
cocktails je me suis alors je vais pas
faire ça une deuxième fois j'en ris jean
voilà donc là vous devenez de plus en
plus la petite amie de claude français
par exemple et si la plus en plus ce que
je veux dire oui très bien je lis tout
va bien et puis bah oui le 11 mars 1978
claude françois est attendu au tube sfp
par michel drucker qui étaient déjà là
il prend une douche debout dans sa
baignoire et alors vous vous rentrez
dans la salle de bain parce que vous
avez cette habitude de vous appuyer
contre la porte
sans fin pour lui dire qu'il allait être
en retard comme toujours et nous avons
commencé à parler de son succès de ce
qu'il faut pour la bbc récemment et puis
mes parlions du week-end diffusion d'un
projet
parce que vous savez il ne met pas tout
était parfait et puis le but que la
langue n'était pas droite et il l'a
juste touché pourra régresser et il
l'avait tellement fait des centaines de
fois avant simplement cette fois ci est
bien le fils était dénudé il est entre
autres actions doit et puis bien sûr il
a remercié une décharge électrique
s'était tracé collet
il est électrocuté devant vous y êtes
vous précipiter pour le tirer hors de la
baignoire heureusement vous aviez à
l'époque des sabots en bois des sabots
suédois en bois donc vous n'êtes pas eu
trop coûté à votre tour parce que sinon
c'était pareil pour vous
kelly slater au secours et bien ils
m'ont dit que ce qu'il a vraiment sauvé
c'est que j'avais ses sabots de bois
j'étais dans la baignoire et est en
porcelaine
les fêtes le courant est passé dans
d'autres
et il pense que j'ai probablement sorti
le cours entre le sait encore mais
j'étais tellement choqué il ya que je
n'ai pas souvenir d'avoir senti quoi que
ce soit vous essayez de le sortir
mais en fait sa main reste accroché à
l'application vous le sortez de la
baignoire l'appliquent vient avec sa
main
un vote à votre avis est vu mourir ou
alors ça a été trop vite et il appelle
le temps de comprendre
non je crois pas qu'il se soit rendu
compte
nous parlions et puis après c'était
terminé en a pas eu tant que se raconte
moi je n'ai pas le temps de réaliser ni
non plus on l'a voulu fait du bouche à
bouche pour essayer de le ramener à la
vie mais rien à faire voilà alors donc
un flash radio annonce officiellement la
mort de claude françois et puis ensuite
arrive là la foule des proches il vous
dit finalement que vous vous avez devant
les yeux comme ça des des amis entre
guillemets de claude françois qui se
servent quoi qu'ils prennent des bijoux
qui prennent des oeuvres d'art vous vous
sentez pas autorisés à leur interdire
donc voyez l'appartement de co2 françois
se vider pratiquement dans la soirée
quoi
pour moi tout se passa au ralenti
lorsque j'ai vu que c'est sale et on
portait des
chaussures dès que soit on les entendait
pas ce que c'est mais il tenait soit
pour le mettre en lieu sûr en tout cas
moi j'étais un peu au ralenti j'avais
l'impression la honte de la dépeint
comme pas comprendre que ce passage
était complètement choqué mais bon j'ai
écrit ça dans mon journal
alors voilà donc les embaumeurs arrive
tout le monde est dans le salon est en
fait dans cet appartement du boulevard
exelmans il n'y avait qu'une seule
chambre à coucher
donc comme
tout le reste de l'appartement est
occupée là c'est absolument incroyable
vous passez à ceux dont la quête jours à
dormir au pied du lit sur lequel il ya
le corps de claude françois
j'étais en état de choc
j'étais très jeune je venais de perdre
l'homme que j'aimais
nous avons la chance qu'il a d'être le
club dans l'appartement à l'époque je ne
savais pas mais ce qui s'est passé ici
tu ne pouvais tout simplement pas sortir
le corps de ce que nous n'avions pas le
choix
de toute façon c'est là que j'habitais
je savais pas où aller
quand on est en état de choc on n'y
pense pas c'est quelque chose que l'on
fait et puis c'est tout je ne me rendais
pas si c'était fou étrange
comme ça
s'il n'était pas mort vous soyez rester
avec lui
cette question 25 ans
bon c'est difficile de dire j'ai commis
quelques années après quelques mois plus
tard il aurait trouvé une très belle
blonde d'autres filles avec de très
beaux yeux qu'il aura intéressé
cette caméra qui tenait alors peut-être
que moi même j'aurais rencontré
quelqu'un d'autre peut être que ce mode
de vie de mort est voilà peut-être qu'on
se serait marié
futur ensemble on peut pas dire je m'en
sers vraiment la salle à couilles
katalin est ce que quand vous étiez avec
lui pendant les 18 mois où vous étiez
avec lui est-ce que vous avez le
sentiment qu'ils étaient fidèles
lorsqu'il l'a fait ce concours
qu'est-ce que c'était déjà miss lice là
j'ai des doutes n'a fait très
honnêtement je n'avais aucune raison de
douter 1
j'espère qu'il était
un scoop merci merci tu as mines
[Applaudissements]
et pour être sûr de ne rien rater de li
na l'a redit tube abonnez vous y mettez
un peu de bleu